I think I got beat up in this last time
I played so stick around and it could be
seeing that happen up again very easily
very easily it could happen again it
could happen again here
seven seconds until kickoff three-to-one
average rating 1885 44 players 30 minute
30 minutes of madness 30 minutes of
madness let me get this madness thing
here this little timeline ticker the
ticker now I could see how much time is
left here alrighty so what do we call
this what do we call this my bishop we
call this my good Bishop is pointing at
their King I'm looking to kill the
knight kill the knight kill the king
kill the knight and then kill the king
if the bishop captures my Bishop it's a
mating - quick kill quick kill
resignation back to tournament two - two
- give me that confetti give me the
confetti everybody wants the confetti if
you're here for the first time you have
no idea what I'm talking about but stay
tuned you might see some of it
it's nothing exciting but um I make it
into something that maybe is exciting
when really it's not okay let's go mmm
Knight takes pawn is that working out
okay okay this isn't working out
it's a move too late it's a move too
late so that there's something like that
a bit earlier but not in this case not
in this case this is just me netting a
fresh minor piece here a fresh minor
piece okay
trade rooks okay and now get my king
doing something here let's guard that
and this isn't the safest flight square
by the way typically you'll want to be
on a dark square but that came with
tempo so that's why I was more inclined
to go with this so let's just make sure
my King could find a good home on these
dark squares I'm close to just being
caught up here timewise and the bishop
is running short on squares so much so
that this is winning more material pawn
push I'll just come back to a dark
Square and I take here and then there
and then here in the night F for
resignation time resignation times six
well somebody has four games in ah man
there's no way there had to be quick
resign errs in that game just being two
minutes and change in two minutes and
change in and there's already four games
played that's crazy
that is crazy town crazy town night here
even crazier move Knight move Knight
move nothing take them you know you want
to take them tape up take them oh look
out look out look out look out look out
look out look out pawn push looking for
mates tricky mates I need a mate I need
a mate
Queen h4 g3 I can't do g3 right away
check oh they're running away they're
running away so there's no quick mate
here there's no quick mate but I get
this pani with check the pony with check
and now I need to be concerned this
could backfire it could backfire very
easily very very easily it could
backfire Oh like this it could backfire
rook in the corner there was ripping the
corner available I think okay now they
are pinned how much time is left let's
do this pawn push around I'm on the road
come on the rook oh they missed it they
missed it tricks everywhere forks forks
and tricks
grab the bishop there on my fees Oh
counter blunder counter blunder right
there you could do it though
tricky night tricky night I got the rook
that Knight is very tricky be very
cautious if you're new to try go to tres
tongue-tied and I'm down on time if you
are new to chess be very cautious about
the tricky Knights tricky Knights
everybody falls for those deadly Forks
okay okay that's a free pawn a free pawn
develop be a developer here get your
pieces out your looks your not your
looks my your pieces some more bad
advice happening here
Knight on c4 Knight on c4 actually
Knight here is even juicier
it's a juicier square now get rid of
that Knight that's in my territory get
rid of them okay I got to chop this guy
first how to chop that guy first and get
my knight doing something exciting
let's support him on c4 if I did c4
right away now this is a reliable home
looking for those reliable homes
that's a queen give me the Queen's
support that Knight support him chop
pile up on this guy he's a weak link
he's the weakest link and now I got f5
incoming F 5 F 2 is under fire though F
2 is under fire my queen is on a dark
square she doesn't like that but she's
gonna have to deal with it for just a
little bit light squares operate on the
light squares and everything isn't this
guy isn't gonna bother you it's not
gonna bother you chop the night he was
too powerful looking for tricky mates
check incoming mates I'm on the bishop
back rank issues everything issues h7 g
7f a eat rd ate too much too much to
defend the queen is out of play no time
left back to turning 2034 20
six games six games have been played by
the top dog am I gonna get paired up
with the top dog oh I gotta get through
to this guy though first I gotta get
through against this guy chop Blackmar
Deema
oK we've been here in the five minute
game already earlier this stream earlier
stream we saw that okay here we go here
we go give me the H file let me play on
the H file give me that H file okay chop
here and then stop f5 stop that f5
advance okay let's do this my dark
square bishop wants to be around here
actually here I was gonna go back to g7
oh man let me do this as scary as it
looks I want to stop that f5 move
capture towards the center chop that
Knight up chop him up I can't deal with
them so chop them up chop them up if you
can't deal with them and now this is
very scary queenside castle okay there
better not be a battery there any time
soon let's come over here rook to g8
oh there's close to being a bad or you
have to watch over this square aged six
break this down break it down break it
down and go after their king oh it's
very scary I gotta run King to g7
they're running with their king they're
running with their king what am i doing
let's come over here get my knight doing
something he should have been doing
something a lot sooner I think actually
no he had a role to play
watch over ePHI but he doesn't have that
job anymore he has another job be a pain
be a pain come over here
defend against a check oh let's do this
activity activity activity where is the
activity where is that activity okay I'm
running scared I'm running scared once
again Bishop there okay Queen trade
Queen trade Queen trade and everything
is okay Queen trade Queen trade I have
to defend my seventh rank defend defend
defend upon uh-oh what's up is if there
is gonna be played they got caught in a
pre move check check
run pond run run team black
me there we go back to tournament 48:37
games
okay still the same same amount of head
no no I don't want not the first time
I've done that either it's not the first
time no I have done that before it's
very scary that window that jumps up and
says do you want to die
I don't want to die I want to play I
want to play stop it stop b5 stop it
before it happens
that's what stop means doesn't it stop
it before it happens just stop it right
now
Oh trouble trouble for black I think
chop a bishop kill the king
that's the plan chop the bishop killed
the King discovered checks in the air
check this is leading to me it's leading
to me otherwise if I did this right away
the King runs around back to tournament
48:42 six away that was a fairly quick
win a fairly quick one let's do this
let's do this here okay no they got to
double those points before I did here we
go chop upon Queen c7 fishing poles
Knight f6 Knight g4 here we go launching
it it's being launched engage engage
engaged mates looking for mates
light-square weaknesses its mate that's
what I'm talking about quick wins you
need the quick wins 64-56 64-56 sneaky
sneaky sneaky sneaky for the Vienna
isn't it f7 kill my opponent f700 not
here now f7 f7 f seven still do
something against f7 what are you doing
right here right here
why there what am i doing light squares
I should be going on the light squares
let's go light squares Castle deadly
discovered checks get rid of this Knight
get rid of this guy push him around
push this night around get back here you
want to get there
stop castling g7 here we go light
squares this is really close to me
really really close to mate I'm on the
night I'm on that night okay let's open
it up grab here grab this pawn light
squares more light squares Queen trade I
don't want the Queen trade b7 I'm on the
night okay I'm taking the night taking
that night oh oh this is brutal
it's brutal I'm on the rough I'm on the
Queen they're gonna give a check I'm
gonna dodge it I'm on the rook on the
road coming guarding my bishop where's
the main hit this Knights I could also
take the rook what am i doing this is
leading to me where's the main where's
the main move move where's my where's
the mate oh they're gonna take my bishop
um right here I get the cleanest double
check there's got to be there should
have been a quicker mate check check and
then mate there we go back to tournament
72 oh I got a lead I got a little bit of
a lead
put the guy in second one he might be
winning he might be close to winning his
game so he could be in the lead like
right now
okay here we go here we go here we go
you could do this here we go team black
team black why don't I just take like
that okay let's go clean clean Oh
capture and then get my Bishop on b7
very quickly very very quickly and then
my rook on d8 stop a pawn push they're
building that up I want my knight on f5
incoming f5 take here don't have enough
on that I could just take it take I have
enough fuel on it take take take take
take and at the end of it what do we
have let me up upon and it's very
simplified okay simplify position and
now get my knight on f6 and King on e7
this is not an inconvenience rook rook
getting to this square might be a
problem okay
double up rooks double up rooks and
pinpoint G 200g two coming under
we fire heavy fire G to rook F to Knight
g4 killer and they come in to e3 could
be even more fuel here we go keep a pig
on the second this is a pig okay check
and then check and if that Knight moves
its Mane maybe it'll move let's throw in
a check just for fun another check come
over here some more checks let's do this
I'm not sure what that's even doing okay
it's a little scary a little scary am I
gonna get made it I know I'm not gonna
get made it not gonna get made it am i
they're down on time doubt they're down
on time no mates no mates please no
mates just move Knight actually it
wouldn't be made what I keep thinking
that it might be made it's not gonna be
made back to tournament 90 80 to 90 80
259 here we go here we go d4 c4 back to
tournament quick resigner a quick
resigner oh i got ten games in 100
points towards the tournament towards
the tournament 100 points no what here
we go let's go here let's go let's go
let's go
why isn't my opponent moving there we go
there you go Queen c7 Knight of six
launching it it's happening again okay
is it okay alright that's alright that's
alright and now they have dark square
issues dark square is dark squares
looking for the dark squares I don't
have the Queen just yet though but now
I'm close to it close to it I have it
quick resigner quick resigner I got the
Queen there in check I'm looking for
more dark squares let's do this my queen
is in a really good spot if this Knight
moves it's close to it's probably me
okay now where's the night going let's
go here okay my queen is hit let's back
up
let's back up and now ho this is a
tsunami of ponds a tsunami oh but wait a
second forks forks everywhere let's take
this guy and then take here and push
this night away here we go
let the pawns push push those pawns push
those puns here we go this is a killer
check this is close to me whoa that's
actually close to me losing my queen
close to me losing my clean let's do
this
there's a fork but everything's alright
everything's our I could have just taken
the night to that would have been nice
check got another Queen another cleaning
what is the mate where does that mean
where is the mate here looking for the
mates back determined they resigned 120
to 1 2000 K we're about halfway there 14
minutes and change here left 14 and
change move your pieces here let's go
how many I missed mouse clicks am I
gonna have miss mouse clicks are not fun
d3 Knight f3 no I don't want to wind up
in a pin it's fall right here focus on
the e4 square actually I should take
this night before it drops a bomb on the
position right here d4 chop it up I
don't want to take that pawn it scares
me I'm not sure why exactly but it just
kind of scares me okay
let's come back here I like my control
over that efore square maybe I'll still
get this pawn one day one day it's gonna
happen it's gonna happen okay maybe not
hit the Queen it's easier to play right
here it's easier to play like this and
now I'm on c3 or c6 and then there's
checks I could grab that pawn check and
then come over here Knight right here is
a killer isn't it it's a killer I'm on
the bishop threatening me they missed me
back to tournament 142 142 point lead
still two-point lead from the top dog
it's it seems like it might be between
us two there's a pretty big gap
they're from second to third hole quick
resigner quick resigner 150 142 I think
I don't know what to think here are we
gonna have a mover here a mover ok d4f
floor no matter what is e5 gonna be
played well ok not right now what's the
what's going on here
stop that bishop from getting to g4 but
I have a space advantage I want to keep
more pieces on the board maybe I want to
okay come back here
Castle rook e1 pawn push in the center
grab that guy grab them and now okay
it's a little bit inconvenient but let's
get here I'm on the night I'm on the
night Bishop d4 Knight to c6 knight c6
is a good idea I think Queen to f200 the
Queen has to go to where the king is or
where it started and now this is this is
brutal isn't it brutal position where's
the night going it's trapped very very
close to I could have played g4 but I
like this just winning of upon guarding
on e5 broke up and over look up and over
Queen trade okay I guess we could go
with the clean trade stop this and then
get my knight doing something good get
my knight doing something good oh that
pounds gonna be won back okay well how
do you deal with that how do you deal
with that let's play here oh I might
leave you losing um more than just upon
might be losing more than just the pun
let's do this and then hit the bishop
okay I have a time edge at least a time
edge and I didn't play this so great I
should have had more to it I could
defend my pawn laterally or bring my
Bishop back but I'm looking more well
okay they forfeit on time 170 150 I have
a 20-point lead Oh
Oh what are we gonna have we're gonna
have C 5 C 5 okay grab this pun oh I
dropped upon I dropped upon I dropped
upon okay
I have development though do something
with your development Oh killer that's a
that's an ugly pawn structure don't look
at this over here it's it's bad it's bad
over there is the bishop close to being
trapped okay okay okay okay okay I got
the bishop here I have a flight square
bishop pair on a flight square look
trade okay do something bishop pair do
something grab a pond I had that forum
over two already didn't I check get the
majority going get the majority going
hey oh okay take my bishop and then it's
a one king upon endgame take here and
then I have an outside pass pond
everybody knows about the outside past
ponds right they're very valuable oh but
I miss played it okay no but the they're
still it's still valuable isn't it it's
still valuable one King and pawn endgame
let's stop that and let me just I don't
know what I want to do okay I want to do
that I want to do that one outside pass
pawn even though it's equal materials
still an asset here very valuable run
pawn run pawn oh he can't be caught
oh they resigned back to tournament they
miscalculated in 191 70 15 games in aged
less than ten minutes still a lot of
time anything can happen
stay tuned stay tuned everybody's after
the confetti everybody is out to get
that first-place confetti okay it's
closed up here let's be careful about
playing what let's do this if I played
Bishop b5 and pawn push that's a mistake
that's a free pun that is a free part
and now how does my pony castle I want
to hang on to my bishop no Knight a 495
just tucked my Bishop back and I guess
they're preparing to go Queen side Queen
side it is but for cover skis for Carew
skis there it is
I got a ruck I'm on the bishop with
check where do they go b4 I want to
maintain this open it up open it up
until the rock moves only then will I
push or only then will I take it's
opened up it's opened up and now let's
do this at night here no no no pin that
night and then go here let's give up
that guy and then do this are they gonna
give up the blight square Bishop light
square Bishop is mine this is a good
spot for my queen queen a 8 a 5 kill the
night oh oh this can't be good
this can't be good light squares light
squares light square issues the queen is
overloaded having to watch the rook and
that ok I got this big material edge
trade Queens
okay now pre-move time a lot of pre
moves happening here a lot of premium is
happening function it on light squares
ok just kill this guy go king kokingo
King go King got this pond and then push
this guy where we got got this one and
then this one and then they are they're
out of time 210 210 192 10 197 minutes
and change 7 minutes and change here
let's go here okay let's go g6 let's go
let's go let's go let's go let's go get
rid of this night okay that's a that's a
good one there let's go here I want to
get b5 in okay b5 can I make that happen
b5 are they gonna stop it they're gonna
stop it I just want to break through
even though it's dropping that pond okay
that's a that's an annoying night that
is definitely an annoying night okay I'm
looking to undermine it though
I want to undermine that night and
okay what do I have to do I need to get
to okay I'm on this now twice okay this
is uh this is what I have to defend this
square I can't take here right away
because of an ensuing fork now I could
know now I can't I still couldn't do it
because I need to just move my king I
needed to just move my king ah that was
a blunder a big one a big blunder right
there the night is sort of stranded
let's push this pond oh man this is
really scary right here
I want a Queen trade what's the time
count what's the time count I need to
get the Queen's off that night is ready
to play here
oh what's happening oh that's a good one
okay wait a second I'm on the Brooke
wait is this working out I'm on the
rookie on the bishop they might have
miscalculated they miscalculated
I'm on f7 I'm on f7 I'm on f7 defend
defend everything here pins pins pins
here we go everything's defended right
the the bishop are the rook is defended
checks on e3 how much time I don't
there's a Czech trade we're gonna have a
trade Queen trade here we go pre move
primo primo primo primo primo throw-in
some checks I can't really ok got this
King and pawn endgame who's gonna win
who's gonna win who's gonna win time
they're out of time they're out of time
back determine - 30 - 10 - 30 - 10 169
his third place four minutes and change
four minutes and change I have to keep
winning here I have to keep winning
let's go Network chess o Network chess
versus chess network was that an on
purpose somebody do that on purpose okay
let's go here
no no mouse lips let's go maybe I'm
launching it Castle kingside okay they
may be sniff that one out they sniff
that one out let's go here maybe Knight
g4
okay there goes my light-square bishop
there he goes the light square bishop
pond push it spin this night and then
pod push pin the night and then upon
push Queen back though okay now I got it
I got that night there is no h6
sometimes would be an h6 and then G five
way to get out of this pin but that's
not available
ladies paying him on this bishop and
it's looking good resignation come on
they're dumb material very very soon I
got the night I'm on the bishop I'm on
the rook they can't Castle I'm posting
here this bishops out of play
94 96 check that's a killer check isn't
it where's the record of your dg8
incoming d6
oh I missed that okay well I got the
bishop at the end of it I got this and
then I'm on the Queen still looking for
some good things right here Queen d6
Queen b6 or just get a Knight to g5
looking for that f7 square f7 square
coming up Knight g5 they're down on time
20 seconds 19 18 17 where we got an on
mover no no non movers I'm on the Queen
I'm on the Queen this could be a pre
move pretty move time primo I don't have
any time here I don't have any time
let's come back here f7 f 7f 7mate very
soon very soon check check
oh my knight can be taken okay they're
down and tied back to tournament two
fifty two thirty two fifty two fifty
oh wait a second wait a second it's it's
a tie - fifty - fifty but that person
that that top guy is uh what that top
guy is uh what am I trying to say the
top guy is having a win on tiebreaks
tie break win take the knight just take
it it's free it's a free night it's a
free one I promise it's free just take
it
nothing bad will happen
oh it's very scary Queen trade okay just
take the night just take them
there's checks and stuff take that night
oh oh oh I gotta go here there was night
tricks right there night tricks would
have been right there
okay go tonight go night I don't have
anything chase this guy way just take
this night just take them come over here
and then I'm gonna push my H pawn okay
now he could go here at least could go
there open this up get to f4 f4 f4 okay
okay oh it's pretty scary over there
over here I need to defend I needed to
defend over here h3h3 checks everywhere
I don't know if I should have captured
like that
oh I'm dropping no I'm not dropping
anything get the Queen's off and then
get my [ __ ] up doing something my
knight isn't a good spot how much time
is left how much time a minute a minute
to win it a minute for a minute for
checks double up my knight is in a good
spot a really really good spot and their
Knight is out of play
take this and then I get the night I got
the night checks looking for mates back
to tournament they forfeit another time
to 70 to 50 45 seconds that guy's
probably trying to win he's really close
to winning how much time 41 seconds 41
seconds can I get this if I get this way
and I think I have it for sure I'm up a
pond come up upon and what else what
else what else what else
LightSquared Bishop spend this f4 f4 I'm
not going to take my bishops undefended
here let's back up checks I should no no
no no no no don't you have 14 seconds oh
if that guy won and that's it all right
it's not gonna happen it's not happening
is it bishop check get that night out of
there check out d7 check on d7 what is
it what is it what is it
second place confetti is the first loser
man what wasn't it tight it was a tie
look at that how did I lose on tiebreaks
how did I lose on tiebreaks I'm
complaining man